[Music]
time now for our seen and unseen segment
where we expose what's really going on
behind the big cultural stories of the
day and here now to fill us in is Fox
News contributor best-selling author
Raymond Arroyo all right Raymond let's
start with this columnist for The
Washington Post Ruth Marcus who used to
just focus on politics and I think the
core it a little bit and now she wrote a
column about you know if she had a Down
Syndrome child he would have aborted the
child right well the title was I would
have aborted a fetus with Down syndrome
women need the right which is terrifying
but she goes in and she talks about when
she had two pregnancies and she took the
Down syndrome test and then she writes
of her own pregnancies I'm going to be
blunt here that was not the child I
wanted she said if it had been positive
that was not the child or the choice I
would have made you can call me selfish
or worse but I am in good company that
evidence is clear that most women
confronted with the same unhappy
alternative would make the same decision
as you can imagine people are terrified
and were horrified when they realize oh
all these kids who are amazing angels
who are kids with Down syndrome and
who've changed families and it's yeah it
can be
it is really challenged how do they feel
after reading that well the horrifying
thing that was not the child I wanted
what other children don't you like Ruth
I mean what other qualities are genetic
abnormalities no ma'am
don't you like and remember know what if
you screen for cancer you know I had
breast cancer you Green freaked out now
we don't we got one green for eye color
you can screen for sex you can screen
for hair color what if you don't like
those attributes of a child how about
your own staff your political
designation with that well I don't know
if they can test not that one yet wonder
what you want right now that's coming
here's the keeper out you mentioned it a
moment ago anyone who's spent time
around children with Down's they have
such a capacity for love and empathy
Ruth Marcus needs to spend a little more
time with them she not learned something
unless the more happy alternate now
what's going on the five-year
anniversary of Pope Francis and the
white smoke and I was like that I
remember you or obviously are in on a
competing network we won't mention
but you and I remember your face you
were support you were kind of surprised
yes I was anyway so what's going on with
this PR campaign that seems to be
launched by the Vatican five years later
well as you're seeing this is footage
from a new documentary called Pope
Francis a man of his word here's what
most people say that you're the Pope
well word well it Wim Wenders who's a
Academy we have nominated documentarian
he was recruited to do this by the
Vatican okay a Monsignor da do di grano
he runs the communications department
why is the Vatican funding a film about
their boss but they are and it's a it's
a puppy that the Pope looks into the
camera talks about his psychological
concerns his concerns for the poor you
see the touchy-feely video here the
question is why alive years later some
are saying this is an effort to insulate
the Pope and protect him from criticism
which he has encountered over the last
five years because of the changes to
church teaching practice and doctrine
and that's a big concern when Benedict
and John Paul wrote their big
biographies their big books those things
are huge bestsellers what happened to
this Pope moving books this Pope are
they moving a lot lot of body has not
I'm told he has not had a New York Times
bestseller yet and now the Vatican is
embroiled now in its own difficulty
today the news came out and this is a
big blunder black eye for the Vatican
there was a letter they released we'll
put a picture of it up from Pope
Benedict affirming that Pope Francis and
he are in continuity internal continuity
so no doctrine is changing don't worry
yeah you know change coming there see
that letter they released yeah they
smudged out the end of it so you
couldn't read what was next
what people don't realize is those 11
books of theology that you see on the
right-hand side of your screen this was
designed to bolster Pope Francis's
theological heft and here your Pope
Benedict saying we are in continuity
turns out if you read the rest of the
letter which no one could read until
today it said I don't have time to read
the book so I really can't pass judgment
on his theological virtues turns out
they completely misrepresented what Pope
Benedict said for all the people
watching out there Vatican what is this
all out yeah The Da Vinci Code stuff my
nose running you have yet to Pope's okay
you can't have too public
no you had we had one has resigned and
retired that it was always gonna cause a
problem I mean that's like your real
deal you're dealing with two popes
just cause a problem if you don't need
the former Pope to vouch for you and
apparently now the Vatican feels it
would have Pope Francis all right can I
get in a separate job like that we that
we're gonna do this I'm gonna do this in
the next segment but I want your view on
this before Hollywood is now trying to
cleanse itself of Harvey Weinstein
completely so they're doing these
inclusion riders in contracts and in
their in their you know production
contracts they have to be have represent
people of all backgrounds in films in
front of the camera behind the camera so
people with disabilities different
ethnicities different agenda I'll be
late so I'll be looking for albino
Pope's and and and people receiving here
in LA but Matt Damon and Ben Affleck I'm
really talking about it but do you think
this is gonna really change filmmaking
by the better no this is a cya move but
you'll get into I'm gonna get I just had
to get your take on Slater